So, should you use a vector graphic or
a raster graphic?
Well in this case, the star is pretty
simple and pretty regular shape.
So I think it's safe to say
a vector graphic is the way to go,
especially if you want to
scale it with your app.
And then should you inline it or
set its source to an external file?
For this question,
I'm actually accepting both answers,
because you could argue either way.
For inline, it's safe to say
a star is a pretty simple shape.
You could pretty easily create
it with an SVG file and
just simply inline that
without adding too many bytes.
If you're reusing an image,
it does make sense to make it external,
which means you'll be
able to cache it and
then not reload it every time
a user visits a new page.
So in this case, it really depends,
and if this were a real app,
you'd just test it to find
out which method is faster.